today we're going to dig deep into the
topic of white nationalism
extremism and radicalization this is a
topic we've covered a lot over the years
on the david pakman show we're going to
be looking at some of my
interviews that i've done with
extremists we will be talking about
paths into
and out of radicalization including the
effect of the internet on this and this
is the first time we're trying this
okay we've tried uh having guest hosts
in when i am not on the show we've tried
running old shows on days that i am not
on the show
and today we are trying something
totally different this is a deep dive
themed episode into the topic of white
nationalism
and extremism let's not delay any
further and get right into it i do hope
to hear back from you
about what you think about this format
what do you want us doing on days where
there is not
a new topical david pakman show either
for
travel reasons or vacation or whatever
the case
may be let's get right into it
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
it's great to have mark potok back on
the program he's senior fellow at the
southern poverty law center and
editor-in-chief
of the intelligence report i was just
reviewing
uh really over the last few days but in
a lot of detail over the last day mark
the new intelligence report it talks
about the rise of extremism in the
united states during 2015.
let's sort of start with the most basic
question which is
in what areas are you seeing this
increase in
extremism what types of groups and
individuals
well oddly enough in two very different
types of groups
clan groups and what we call a black
separatist groups which are groups like
the nation of islam the new black
panther party and so on
uh we think the klan groups uh grew uh
at least numerically quite spectacularly
we think that actually the numbers
slightly overstate or somewhat overstate
the growth of the klan because what
really happened
uh was two major clan groups dissolved
and essentially their members
uh redistributed themselves in a batch
of new small groups
that said though the clan last year uh
was
uh to a very real extent kind of
re-energized
and this was on the basis of the battle
over the confederate flag
that followed the dillon roof massacre
in charleston
in june i'm sure our listeners and
viewers will remember that
uh roof was uh took a lot of pictures of
himself with the confederate battle flag
that resulted in a very serious
criticism of the flag
flag was taken down a number of places
like the state grounds in south carolina
and alabama where i
am and that in turn uh ignited a kind of
backlash to the backlash and we saw uh
encountered a full
pro 364 battle flag rallies around the
south
uh in the aftermath of the uh charleston
massacre
so it really it lit up the clan groups
it was not only clan groups
doing these kinds of rallies but they
were very much involved
and uh in a sense the other end of the
ideological spectrum black hate groups
uh uh grew and they grew really uh for
the same reasons that
uh uh black groups that are not at all
hate groups like uh
black lives matter also grew and that is
uh the very large amount of national
attention
that was paid to police violence against
black men
uh while that certainly helped black
lives matter and probably other black
civil rights groups grow
it also gave some real energy uh to
these very anti-white
anti-semitic uh and anti-gay black hate
groups
it's incredible you know we we've been
talking quite a bit
about the sort of coalescing and
catalyzing
of a lot of these extremist groups by
the candidacy of donald trump and aside
from whether you believe that donald
trump's ideas or his authentic ideas are
sort of a fabricated and concocted set
of statements
meant to coalesce angry voters it's been
amazing that you've seen
both former kkk leader david duke
and nation of islam's louis farrakhan
both incredibly anti-semitic but
typically would be on opposing sides of
so many issues
both come together and say that they
believe donald trump is the best path
forward
talk to me about your sense of this are
we seeing i mean is this just politics
makes strange bedfellows or
what's your analysis of that well they
aren't all that different
uh they are both racial nationalists in
a sense
well not in a sense they straight up
racial nationalists they want to form uh
nations that are composed entirely of
people who look like them
and you know this is not the first time
we've seen the nation of islam
uh in a sense cozying up to white
supremacists i mean we've had very very
serious uh white supremacists for
instance tom metzger the head of white
aryan resistance
uh actually attend nation of islam
events
uh you know kind of pat louis farrakhan
on the back
and make a donation so the idea
among these groups is although they
can't stand one another uh
individually uh they believe that they
are all fighting for the same thing and
in a sense they are these racially
homogenous many nations
i have a question for you that i asked
tim wise a couple of weeks ago and he
had one analysis of it and i'd be
curious since this is really what what
you're looking at on a regular basis
what your sense of it would be
do you believe that the sort of current
broader reality of the republican party
and and in that i'm including the
candidacy of donald trump
is it coalescing and sort of mobilizing
and catalyzing
existing extreme ideas that that are
already there
or are people being sort of convinced or
brought
over to that side by these candidacies
no i think uh in large part they're
appealing to feelings that are already
there
uh the feelings that are there might not
be
uh very well thought out or very precise
and exactly uh what it is these people
want
uh but you know trump is clearly uh
trump and other uh republican candidates
are truly
clearly tapping in to a lot of
anger and it is a kind of white
nationalist anger it's an anger that the
white working class
white lower middle class uh are in
trouble wages are falling and so on of
course as
much as they are for minorities uh but
in the case of
uh white workers there's real resentment
because it wasn't always so
so i i think that uh the truth is uh
when you listen to trump he is speaking
in large part to the very same
constituency
that the clan tries to address and you
know i'm not suggesting
uh nor do i think that uh every or most
working class or
middle class whites are our clansmen i
don't think that's so
but there's a very large subset of
people within those groups
who really are angry about the way the
country's changing demographically
against the financial strains on them
against cultural changes like the
advance of same-sex marriage and so on
uh and are looking for someone to
represent them someone mad as hell like
they are
uh and trump fits that uh description
very well
and i think he understands it perfectly
i i don't think that there's a whole lot
of subtlety
uh in trump's uh extreme reluctance to
denounce
david duke or even admit who he uh that
he knows who he is
uh or characterize the plan uh as as
you know a a nasty group what's your
sense as we sort of go
forward and there's still questions of
course as to who will be both the
republican and
republican and democratic presidential
nominees
if on the republican side my question
would be if it is not trump if it is
marco rubio or ted cruz
two candidates of hispanic heritage
do you expect that that will become
a a prominent factor in how it will
impact extremist nativist xenophobes
nationalist or do you believe that
because in the same way sort of that
uh individuals that might otherwise be
misogynistic
liked sarah palin because of her
conservative values
that the hispanic background of cruz and
rubio might become sort of background or
irrelevant
to extremists that otherwise like their
ideas
look i don't think it'll matter much
first of all i think rubio is out
so we're really talking about cruz uh
and you know white supremacists
know perfectly well that uh one of
trump's daughters uh converted to
judaism
uh that he's made lots and lots of very
strong pro-israel
uh comments and so on and yet they are
willing to live with that
uh i think that's probably going to be
true cruz at all in the unlikely event
that he were to win the nomination
uh you know i mean i think the fact is
is that cruz's politics aren't
all that terrifically different than
trump's uh you know he's a very
nasty fellow uh and uh
has uh associated himself with a lot of
other nasty fellows
i mean where he was at last night uh
listening to the returns this
redneck uh bar was a place run by
really a nasty racist man with a long
history
of anti-black commentary so uh you know
i think cruz is not that awfully
different
it's true that as a sort of technical
matter he's uh he's latino
uh but i really uh don't think that that
will turn off
very far right-wing voters and on the
democratic side we we don't really know
right now
how far bernie sanders candidacy will go
i've started to see
the sort of uh typically regurgitated
anti-semitic talking points start to
appear on youtube in some conspiracy
circles
about bernie sanders but far by and
large
it has not been the big narrative about
bernie sanders it's been his democratic
socialism rather than his judaism
what would you expect to see if bernie
sanders
continues for the long haul in this
democratic primary process
with regard to his jewish background
well i think if he seemed like a real
contender
uh to actually win the democratic
nomination it probably would become
more front and center for white
supremacists
you know that said in an odd way there
are aspects
of what sanders stands for uh that
portions at least of the radical right
don't disagree with
uh you know i mean if you are a real
national socialist you believe
uh in the government uh doing a great
deal i mean many of the people i cover
believe
absolutely uh in cradle to grave health
care
uh in all kinds of programs like that to
support the community of course the
community to them
is only you know lilly white uh pure
aryans uh and everyone else is excluded
but nevertheless there is
uh there are some elements of far-right
ideology that are not totally
uh remote from sanders that said i think
look i mean they see sanders
as a leftist a man of the left which he
is and so
you know basically they will despise him
all right mark potok senior fellow at
the southern poverty law center
editor-in-chief of the intelligence
report mark it's always so great to talk
to you thanks for being on
david thanks for having me i really
appreciate it so the cato institute um
which blows me away on face value
pat that the cato institute shared this
it's more of a
libertarian-leaning outfit but they
reported on a general
government accountability office report
that states that traditional
right-wing extremists make up a vast
majority of domestic terrorist incidents
now they're citing data between
september 12 2001
and today between uh since september 12
2001
there have been 85 violent extremist
incidents that resulted in
death 62 of the 85 which represents 73
percent
were committed by quote-unquote
traditional right-wing
violent extremist groups uh 27
23 of the events 27 of the total uh were
committed by quote unquote radical
islamic violence
uh so this is this goes against what
most people fear right the general fear
pat in the society is that you're going
to get
attacked by some type of islamic
terrorism and this is the entire push
that we have in the government is like
100 behind you know uh getting rid of
radical right-wing terrorism but i mean
getting rid of islamic terrorism but the
real threat in the united states
since september 11th has been
right-wing terrorism right and the top
reason in the world for terrorism at
this point
is radical islamic terrorism but in the
united states has experienced since
since 9 11 it's been right-wing
terrorism i think environmental
terrorism even ranks higher than
islamic terrorism and and to be sure
right so i'm sure the one of the first
things people are going to comment and
say well why didn't he include september
11th
uh why does this this research not
include september 11th well
you know based on the method methodology
that they use they're not they're not
counting the number of people that were
killed they're counting the number of
events so
technically they could throw in
september 11th and still get about the
same results so you would go from 85
violent events and go to 86 violent
events
and then you will still have 62 of the
86
from radical right wing traditional
terrorists
and then 24 would be so it doesn't
really change
the analysis when you talk about
violence and terroristic violence here
in the united states
we have more of a reason to be fearful
of billy bob
if i could be stereotypical than we do
ahmed yeah and i mean the right wing
talking point at least as it as far as
donald trump is concerned
is that we have to eliminate muslim
immigration into the united states
because of the threat of terrorism but
given this study and
we've actually known this for quite some
time uh people like me should be
profiled right it should be
young white males because in instances
of terrorism that's the group that tends
to do it the most in this country
uh should should i leave i feel
threatened now i feel like oh yeah
sorry i don't mean to make this
difference between us this is this i
have enough room to run i have enough
room to run
i sorry to make light of a very serious
topic but
here's the next part of this right
there's a reason that we're afraid of
of of ahmed and not bill and that's
because our media
according to the same study um they
examined
les lexis nexus and uh they
pulled together reports between 2011 and
2015
reports on terrorism there was 449
percent more
coverage of radical islamic terrorism
than there was
traditional right-wing terrorism in the
united states
449 percent compared to the reality that
since 2011
2001 rather 73 percent of the violent
experiences
that led to death in the united states
has been at the hand of right wing
so our media they're called they're
complicit in this
in this perception that we should be
afraid in the united states to be clear
that we should be fair afraid of radical
islamic terrorism when the reality the
real threat is
traditional right-wing terrorism and of
course racism plays a big part into that
too
because you know typically when we think
of muslims we think of people from the
middle east
so there's this outsider perspective of
trying to fear the other that the media
likes to play up
and then there's also the tactics that
the terrorists use so maybe
uh radical islamic terrorists would be
more inclined to use bombs rather than
guns and yes we have a gun culture in
this society so
we're not as fearful of that right that
that's a great distinction right
you know we we really won't even
consider in many cases what
what one of these people would do as
terrorism we won't qualify it as
terrorism
and that's probably plays a huge role in
it as well we also have a president
who will not say who will say everything
about
radical islamic terrorism and say
absolutely nothing about
right-wing terrorism that has had an
uptick since he was elected so
that plays into the equation as well but
there's one last thing and i don't want
to get your last word on it
one last thing that plays into this is
the fact that you know if you think
about it
if you look at the commercials that are
run on cnn msnbc and fox news the
commercials that are run
are coming from defense contractors um
northrop gun grundmann um lockheed
martin
you know they run and if you think about
it there is no money whatsoever
for the defense contractors in waging a
war against right-wing terrorism in the
united states
there is plenty of money in waging war
against islamic terrorism
abroad so if you think about it there is
a vested interest into keeping the
conversation being about
449 percent more coverage on radical
islamic terrorism because there's
actually money
in the fear that americans have of right
of of radical islamic terrorism
yeah and that conflict is patently clear
because i don't know about you but i'm
not out there buying
aircraft carriers and planes and
ammunition and all this stuff
exactly directly to appeal to the media
outlets ex
100 so it has absolutely nothing to do
with the audience that's watching
because it's not a single person who's
watching
msnbc who's going to buy something from
lockheed martin but you know
you you said it best so but this is the
problem and and and there's so many
layers of of responsibility to this
but the fact of the matter is in the
united states since
september 11 2001 there have been
more incidents of traditional right-wing
terrorism
than there has been radical islamic
terrorism yet there has been 449 percent
more coverage of right of islamic
terrorism
than traditional right-wing terrorism
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i've been talking to you for a while now
and i even did a couple of interviews
about the sort of signaling
that donald trump has done to white
nationalists
and white supremacists with the things
that he says and the policies that he
proposes
and i've made the point before and even
white nationalists have made the point
before
on this program that when trump like
stops sort of short
of what would be a much more obvious
identification
with white nationalism or white
supremacy or
sort of established xenophobia if donald
trump's statements have the effect of
coalescing those groups
if those extremists see trump
as the best path the most likely path
to getting the world that they want it
kind of doesn't matter whether trump is
personally a white supremacist or a
white nationalist or anti-semitic or
racist or xenophobic or whatever
because the impact on those groups and
on policy
still remains if that's how he's
perceived by those individuals and
richard spencer uh one of the most
well-known white nationalists i think at
this point i would say in the world
was on the program and he said we get
trump can't say all of the things
we are choosing to ignore that trump's
daughter converted to judaism and
trump's son-in-law is jewish
we understand the signals he sends and
we see him as our best path forward and
along those lines there's a really
interesting report in the new york daily
news
who spoke to a former white nationalist
named derrick black who's actually the
son of
i think it's don black i forget the name
of another very well-known white
nationalist
and uh derrick black explained it's not
just
trump's rhetoric that signals white
nationalists and his language
but his policies also signal white
nationalists and
first thing i'm going to play a little
clip for you here uh
derrick black was asked about trump not
condemning neo-nazis at the
charlottesville march and he explained
how
a white nationalist would read trump's
statements take a look
would you say also kind of his
unwillingness to
condemn like like the attacks in
charlottesville and he said you know
there was bad people on both sides and
even recently he referred to himself as
a nationalist
do you think that has there been any one
event
that really kind of made you go woe the
fact that he wasn't
willing to condemn charlottesville which
absolutely shocked me because up until
that point
i had thought there's a lot of overlap
in the things that he believes and the
things that white nationalists believe
and that was shocking but it could at
least
feel like if he had the opportunity to
condemn white nationals that he always
would
and he didn't do that and that was very
alarming the fact that he could look at
an outright white nationalist event with
nazi flags
and say that there are some of those
people who are really good at what
they're marching for
is itself good that was just absolutely
mind-boggling and then you get into the
material where
derek black goes on to say during the
interview that when you look at the
package of policies that this
administration has supported or proposed
or
sort of shown an interest in it's a very
clear signal to white nationalists
limiting immigration from we can say it
now [ __ ] countries
and increasing immigration from norway
or moving immigration
from those countries to norway that's a
very clear policy signal
shutting down all muslim immigration
earlier this week talking about
birthright citizenship at a time when
you've got
a lot of the media attention on
immigrants coming from
latin american countries where people
are disproportionately brown
militarizing the border to stop those
asylum seekers
saying as the interviewer mentioned in
that clip i am a nationalist last week
or the week before
when you step back for a second and
realize
that trump's jewish son-in-law isn't
really the important thing here you see
the big picture
and this is an xkkk guy son of one of
the most prominent white nationalists in
the country in the world
explaining how the white nationalists
see trump
and then when you see something like
this next clip
you are immediately if you're a white
nationalist going to say
that is my guy remember when trump did
this i want to ask you about the
anti-defamation league which
this week called on you to publicly
condemn unequivocally the racism of
former
kkk grand wizard david duke who recently
said that voting against you at this
point would be treason
to your heritage will you unequivocally
condemn david duke and say that you
don't want his vote or
that of other white supremacists in this
election
well just so you understand i don't know
anything about david duke okay
i don't know anything about what you're
even talking about with the
white supremacy or white supremacist so
i don't know i mean i don't know
did he endorse me or what's going on
because
you know i know nothing about david duke
i know nothing about white supremacists
and so you're asking me a question that
i'm supposed to be talking about people
that i know nothing about
the idea that trump knew nothing about
it is ridiculous we later found out that
he did but
does the question do you condemn
david duke really need a clarification
24 hours later um relevant quote
andrew gillum gillum recently said about
his opponent ron desantis in florida
now i'm not calling desantis a racist
i'm simply saying
the racists believe he's a racist and
that is what applies here
to donald trump and to this issue
richard spencer has said it
former kkk people are saying it it's the
reality folks
if he is perceived as white nationalist
or xenophobic or whatever else by those
individuals
that's what matters and he's coalescing
and activating them am i wrong
well let me know i'm on twitter at
deepakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman's show
let's uh i think we have time for one
more caller so we're going to go
to we're going back to 717 who wasn't
there before
717 seems to really want to get on so
i'm hoping this time we'll be able to
hear 717. go ahead
hey can you hear me we can who's this
okay yes this is logan how are you good
go ahead logan
okay oh no logan right when you got to
the question you can you're now in the
background it sounds like maybe you've
got a bad
bluetooth setup hello for a bit now
you're done hello
hello can you hear me yes go ahead logan
with a question before we lose you buddy
yes um so candidates like
don blankenship uh the neo-nazi from
california
do you believe do you believe
uh that the media vilifying these people
is giving them free press now
thankfully as you saw on tuesday don
blankenship
lost and was demolished
but um candidates like roy moore
almost won uh donald trump
definitely won uh so do you believe that
the media is somehow culpable for this
well listen here's the thing that you
will any time any extremist is given
any air time of any kind you will get an
argument from some that say
your platform you're giving them a
platform if you didn't give them a
platform they would just go away i think
history tells us that
not giving them a platform actually
allows these ideas to use whatever word
you want
fester or ferment or build power or
whatever
and that um you know the the number of
people
if you put a white supremacist on tv
responsibly right
not as giving them a five minutes to do
a monologue that's unchallenged but if
you put a white supremacist
on tv responsibly with a host or
interviewer who's prepared to engage
them on
on the merits of their ideas whatever
number of people might be
turned to white supremacy by seeing that
interview
will be outdone i believe by the number
of people who will be made aware of the
danger
that these people exist and will be more
vigilant and
sure to the extent that they can that
those ideas don't become mainstream so i
understand the point you're making but i
don't think in the net it actually
works out that way
i think he said thank you but i think
logan might have the worst connection
today
that does it for calls thanks to
everybody that called in we will take
calls again
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show
now on this program we are different
than
some other so-called liberal shows we
use the term
islamic terror some don't islamic terror
is a thing
we discussed the realities that for
example according to a pew forum study
from a couple years ago
out of the 1.62 billion muslims that are
on earth or were at the time
748 million at the time of the survey
believe
that the death penalty is an appropriate
punishment for
adultery that's extreme that's
disturbing and i have no qualms
whatsoever
about telling you that however we also
know on this program that in the united
states
most terrorists are white american-born
men not foreign muslims not people
coming in with refugee status from syria
or from whatever other country
terrorism from muslims terrorism
perpetrated by muslims
receives disproportionately more
attention in the united states from
politicians
from reporters from corporate media and
the reality is
as we've said before right-wing
extremists
pose a much greater threat to people
in the u.s than terrorists connected to
isis or similar organizations and i'll
remind you about the article
in the new york times uh was a few
months ago unc
professor charles kurtzman and duke
professor
david shanzer explained that
islam-inspired terror attacks accounted
for
50 fatalities after the 9 11 attacks
while right-wing extremists accounted
for 337
attacks per year in the decade after 9
11 causing over 250 fatalities so
two really important takeaways and
remember that part of the goal of
terror is to create fear and to create
blow back with the security state and to
make people
live in fear and without privacy okay
so two takeaways here number one in the
united states
you are way more likely to be the victim
of
white u.s born terrorists than
muslim foreign-born terrorists and
it is not very likely at all that you're
going to be the victim of a terror
attack
that is the key takeaway lewis when we
think about what our policies should be
when we think about nsa surveillance
when we think about all of the different
reactions that a country can have
militarily and into intelligence wise
to terror you have to remember it is so
unlikely that you will ever be the
victim of a terror attack living in the
united states doesn't mean we should
ignore that risk doesn't mean we should
say hey
no more tsa no more screening of
refugees none of it doesn't mean we
should say that
but it means that we should not be
living in a hyper scary
world that we create in our own minds
where at any second
any one of us is going to be the victim
of a terror attack it could happen
very very unlikely but we do live in
that world
and it's very apparent with all the
legislation and everything that happened
after
the 9 11. we live in a world where we
have responded
with legislation that yes would suggest
that being a victim of terror is a
likely thing yes
and so that's what we're dealing with
we're dealing with the repercussions of
that the nsa the surveillance
homeland security the airport security
everything everywhere and so
in a way those uh islamic terrorist
attacks
have had a much greater impact
absolutely uh
despite not being as frequent as the
ones we're talking about here and so uh
yeah so
we're still victims i think we're all
victims even local law enforcement
agencies
know the reality of this of the 382
agencies that kurtzman and chanzer spoke
to 74 percent
said anti-government extremism is one of
the top three terrorist threats
in our jurisdiction only 39 percent
said that extremism connected with al
qaeda or like-minded terrorist
organizations
is one of the top three threats so local
law enforcement that seems to base their
opinions
on what is actually happening seems
connected to reality
it's federally and for political reasons
that
we've seen what has happened take place
right um
the the climate of fear that has been
created uh and you know it's gonna take
a long time to get over that
but uh certainly dave i i don't like
living
in a world full of people who are afraid
all the time
and last thing on this your chances of
being
uh killed in a car accident
are so much higher than of being killed
in a terrorist attack
and still people don't wear seat belts
and those are the same people who want
nsa surveillance and all the other stuff
that we know has not prevented terrorist
attacks
you got to start with the most simple
stuff wear your seat belt if you want to
reduce the chance of dying an early
death
or wear your helmet when you're riding
your motorcycle but
dave it's all about personal freedoms um
we can have that debate another time i
suppose freedom and liberty the freedom
not to wear your seat belt and the
freedom to do a lot of other stuff
apparently
let's take a break i'm on twitter at
deepakman lewis is on twitter at lewis
motomety
i've been telling you for years that
domestic extremists who commit crimes
are often terrorists not always but they
are often
terrorists and they should be treated as
such by our legal system and they should
be
identified as terrorists in media
reporting about their cases
very big news for the first time in new
york a white supremacist criminal
has been convicted as a terrorist and
this is really good news and it's very
important news and this incident goes
all the way back to 2017
when 28 year old james harris jackson
went to new york city you might remember
the story because we covered it at the
time
went to new york city and tried to find
black people to
attack and start a so-called race war
eventually he actually um attacked and
killed
timothy kaufman with a sword he pleaded
guilty a few days ago
to murder in the first degree in
furtherance of an act of terrorism
murder in the second degree as a crime
of terrorism
and a number of other charges as well
he's almost definitely going to get the
maximum sentence and he likely would
have gotten that maximum sentence
whether or not there were terrorism
charges here
but this actually does matter because
even in this case
uh in this case the crimes were so
heinous
that he would likely be spending his
entire life in prison no matter what
but what really matters here is that the
perpetrator said
he went to new york to kill black men as
a quote
declaration of global total war on the
negro race
he went to do this to dissuade white
women
from engaging in integration interracial
relationships so what this means
legally is that if you carry out a crime
in the name of white supremacy
it will be treated as an attack not only
on the specific victims that you
attacked but on the population at large
because what's at issue here
is intimidation an attempt to coerce a
population he went to kill black people
to intimidate all black people not
because he had a particular
grudge or pre-med meditated this attack
on this particular individual mr kaufman
he went in order to scare people out
of participating in interracial
relationships so this is good news
and it brings up another issue that many
people are aware of domestic terrorism
is not a federal crime
okay international terrorism is a
federal crime but domestic terrorism is
not
and what this causes is an inequality
when you have muslim terrorists in the
united states with ties to
saudi arabia or yemen or another country
they are charged rightly so as
international terrorists under federal
law but when you have american-born
white dudes who are of course the
majority of the terrorists in the u s
they are not charged federally with
terrorism
since that is not a federal crime so
this is not about
the punishments because usually these
domestic terrorists
are receiving serious punishments
because their crimes are so heinous
it's just about calling things what they
are pat these are terrorists it affects
media coverage
because when there aren't terrorism
charges
media reports are also less likely to
call it what it is
terrorism because in some legal sense it
often is not
so it's not a desire to stack up all
these
criminal charges on people who are going
to get life in prison anyway
it's about reality it's about calling
things what they are and we've got to be
even-handed here when it comes to
domestic versus international terrorism
yeah domestic terrorism not being a
federal crime that's absolutely crazy so
if you take someone like
timothy mcveigh who killed 168 people in
uh the 1996 oklahoma city bombing
technically the the terrorism itself
wasn't a federal crime now he committed
an act against the he blew up a federal
office building so i'm sure there were
some
federal crimes involved with that but
the terrorism itself wasn't
we definitely have to change that yeah
and i know that a lot of people say
david you're focusing on semantics when
the climate's falling apart and all of
this other stuff
yeah i don't think i mean listen we can
walk and chew gum at the same time
this is actually an issue because so
much of our perception of the issue of
terrorism
depends on the words that are used to
describe it
and the way that media covers these
issues and
at least one element that would help
have a more sort of even-handed and fair
framework around the reporting would be
to actually have domestic terrorism be a
federal crime
uh so that's that good news out of new
york horrible crime
horrible that it happened but at least
some glimmer of something positive or at
least sensible
coming out of the results from from the
trial there and those
terrorism charges being applied to what
is just out and out white supremacy
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
for this week's classic interview we're
going to revisit my discussion with
claire
connor who talked to us about how
individuals
can and often do escape their families
extremism and this is a particularly
relevant concept right now
with the coalescing catalyzing and
fomenting
of really horrible extremism record
number of hate incidents under president
donald trump and this discussion over
how much is trump directly fomenting
that
and how much is happening by virtue of
the sort of cult of personality
that his supporters have created around
him the discussion with clara connor
uh never more relevant at least during
the time of the david pakman shows
existence than it is today
we will go to my interview with her from
nearly six
years ago and think about it as i
reviewed it over the weekend
thinking about it in the context of the
trump presidency
and the coalescing and fomenting of
extremism that we've been tracking now
for more than two years
today claire connor is with us her new
book wrapped in the flag as her story of
being raised by extremist parents in a
household that embraced the john birch
society and the radical right
she was able to escape and lead her life
as a progressive
claire it's so great to talk to you and
i'm on this program we do a lot
with extremism and many times we talk to
extremists just last week we had a
a white separatist self-described and
talked with him about
his goals and his ideas and kind of
where his beliefs came from
you have a very different situation
which is that
your parents were two of the first
chicago members of the
john birch society and you were in a
situation where the upbringing
clearly should have led you maybe to be
a right winger but that's not how it
ended up so let's start first with kind
of your upbringing and what that was
like
well first of all thank you very much
for having me david i'm
really excited to have this opportunity
to talk to you and to your audience
first thing i think people need to
understand is the john birch society in
the 1960s
was the best funded most successful
and most powerful right-wing populist
organization that the united states had
ever seen
we'd had populist right-wing movements
before but in this particular case the
founder of the john birch society
a felony named robert welsh actually
figured
out how to get all of the membership
working on the same thing at the same
time
and he used a very monolithic approach
so what he said
is what the john birch society did this
is not an organization that embraced the
concept of democracy
either within itself or for the country
at large
my father was the first member of the
john birch society in the city of
chicago
and my mother was the second they
believed so much
in the cause that in 1959 they wrote a
check
to the john birch society for two
thousand dollars for two life
memberships
that would be like you david writing a
check for twelve thousand
five hundred dollars today for
membership
they were true believers my father
became a member of the national council
in 1960 when then just after the
national council which is an advisory
group to robert welsh
just after it was founded so
interestingly enough
he remained on the leadership for 32
years
this is not a man who changed his views
backtracked
or rethought his positions he remained a
true believer all of his life
and even after i left the birch society
he was constantly recruiting me back
into the cause
so as you were growing up i mean what at
what point did you
you know for a certain time kids kind of
don't know that there are really other
options right it's just what your
parents tell you that's the status quo
it's your frame of reference period
what was the catalyst that made you
start to kind of reevaluate where you
were politically
well i think people think that there was
like this moment
when i left out you know left up and
said i'm not doing this anymore actually
the story is much more complex than that
and i think it's an
object lesson for anybody who thinks
about how people live
in extremism it takes a long time
i tell audiences it was like one step
forward two back
a half a step forward i wanted very much
to please my parents i loved my father
i loved my mother and they were very
powerful
strong and compelling people so it took
probably 25 years of
reading and struggle before i was
finally able to say this is not
my vision for america i don't believe in
what the john birch society is preaching
now the first step forward for me
had to do with meeting a felon named
revolo oliver
when i was 14 years old revello oliver
was one of the john burke society
leaders
like my dad and once my father became a
leader
a whole parade of birchers went in and
out of our life
our home in chicago was like the
stopping point
for birch leadership revello oliver used
to come over quite often
and he was a fellow who was very
educated a classics professor but he had
a profound
impact on my parents because revello
oliver did not believe that there was a
holocaust during world war ii
so suddenly even though i'd been raised
in a jewish neighborhood
and had learned about the holocaust when
i was a little girl even before the word
holocaust was applied to the wars in
germany
suddenly my father was saying well
you know the the germans were really
just trying to stop the communists
from taking over in germany i thought my
father had lost his mind
and i was positive revel oliver had
helped him
now that may not sound of particular
significance to people
until you think about this dr revolo
oliver
if you google him today you'll find out
that revelo oliver is the father of the
neo-nazi movement
right so would you talk to that white
supremacist last week that you
were sharing about david he would have
been
very knowledgeable about revolut oliver
revolo
oliver had coined the term
hollow hoax and that term is used
all across the anti-semitic of
far right today in addition revolo
oliver talked to app to andrew pierce
who was originally a bird shirt
pierce talked him into writing a novel
about the white supremacist takeover of
america
that novel is called the turner diaries
now interesting about the turner diaries
when the police
stopped timothy mcveigh about an hour
after the oklahoma city bombing
what did they find in his car but
excerpts
from the turner diaries incredible
incredible
you know we we only have a few minutes
left and there's a lot of other things i
wanted to touch base with you on so a
few
things i wanted to ask about one was
before your parents passed away
ultimately what was your relationship
like with them or how did it change as a
result of your
changed political views it was a very
very contentious relationship i lived in
the same town with my parents so i had a
lot of
responsibility and concern toward the
end of their lives
and did everything i could to help them
but they were very very angry i think
one of the keys to understanding the
far right is they are angry they are
angry
they are angry at the government and
they are angry at people who don't agree
with them
so my mother used to say you are a
disgrace to the country
and to our family but the most important
thing that i want to share with people
is i learned something from living in
the radical right
i learned that extremism breaks families
it breaks families
apart it destroys relationships it is
full of a sort of
paranoia and hate that's really bad for
families
but more important than that i don't
want extremism to break my country
so that's why i wrote my book to share
the story of what it's like
growing up in extremism how i escaped
and why it matters to the united states
today
so how did you now now with your
children
taking in what you learned and what
you've experienced with the dynamic with
your parents
how how is the conversation about
politics happening around your children
because the case could be made
that maybe they on their own might
choose
right-wing beliefs and it could be just
as wrong for you to push progressive
beliefs on to them
i think that there would be diverging
views about that but how have you
handled politics with your children
well i was always pretty much policy
wonk david because i was raised in a
political family i find politics
very interesting and for a very long
time my kids thought it was republican
interesting huh so it was
what i wanted my children to understand
is there's a difference between
pop conservatives and extremists there's
a big
difference and extremist philosophies
are dangerous to the governance of the
united states
i think we actually need a
viable second party we need a gop
we do you can't have a one-party system
that works
at all well with our constitutional
structures but the point is
that what's happened in the republican
party today
is that this radical right has taken it
over
so you see john boehner you hear
policy ideas prescribed by the
leadership of the gop which sound
exactly like when i
what was prescribed by the john burke
society
way back when so it's a repetition of
the same sort of
we hate the government we want to hobble
the government
we want to dismantle the government long
before grover norquist got the idea of
drowning the government in the bathtub
the john birch society believed in that
so
i think there's a big difference at the
same time
i also think that we have to be clear as
progressives that we need
to talk about how governance works and
what america should look like
i do not believe it should look like
anything imagined
by the john birch society we've been
speaking with claire connor the new book
is wrapped in the flag make sure to take
a look at that book
excellent read claire thank you so much
for being on us on with us today and we
will be back with plenty more
right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
you